après les attentats du 11 septembre
dernier l'amérique a glorifié ses héros
les pompiers de new york qui au prix de
leur vie souvent on assurer le sauvetage
des rescapés et des tours de manhattan
six mois plus tard
plusieurs d'entre eux attaquent la ville
en justice craignant pour leur santé à
venir car ils ont pendant plusieurs
semaines respiré des gaz et des
poussières sur leur lieu de travail
pascal golomer attristant l'ombre c'est
la première intervention de l'après midi
une simple fuite d'eau la routine toute
la journée
le lieutenant o'connell et son équipe
sillonnent les rues de greenedge il est
à deux pas du wall trade center le matin
du 11 septembre il était parmi les
premiers à se rendre sur place
onze d'entre eux ne sont jamais revenus
quant aux autres ils sont longtemps
restés à travailler sur les décombres
des tours jour et nuit sans se douter
alors des conséquences pour leur santé
j'ai encore les voies respiratoires
encombré avec un sifflement dans la
poitrine et vraiment je ne me sens plus
comme avant et je ne suis pas le plus à
plaindre
un de mes hommes souffrent de bronchites
et notre capitaine est en arrêt maladie
depuis six semaines
car les sauveteurs ont absorbé toute
sorte de poussière et de vapeurs
toxiques en ne portant souvent qu'un
simple masque de papier bien peu
efficace
les équipements adéquats ont été livrés
en masque au bout d'une semaine un
retard inexcusable sinon palmer d'orgue
pompiers lui aussi il a passé la
première semaine sur les ruines
il porte plainte aujourd'hui contre la
ville pour négligence et lui réclame 10
millions de dollars mais espère un
règlement à l'amiable
il s'agit pour nous d'être couverts au
cas où on tomberait gravement malade à
l'avenir ou même en cas de décès faut
bien y penser
vous savez c'est horrible de travailler
là bas et si dans cinq à dix ans on a un
gros pépin de santé
il faut bien que nos familles soient
dédommagés
plusieurs centaines de pompiers ont déjà
rempli un dossier de plainte peut-être
n'y at-il jamais jusqu'au procès mais
les héros de new york volts en tout cas
prouvé que cinq mois après les attentats
il ne se contente plus de l'admiration
des habitants ni les remerciements de la
municipalité